the housing market continues to attract
people into the valley others are
struggling to pay their mortgage that's
a common concern one lender says but
help is available to keep you in your
home
it was very exciting to have my own
place jorge gamboa can't stop smiling
after becoming a homeowner earlier this
year but his mortgage for the
two-bedroom home near decatur and oaky
he says quickly became difficult to keep
up everything started getting so
expensive they spend so much money and
everything we just tried to catch up
he's not alone according to andrew
levitt from pif lending as homeowners
tried to stay current on their mortgage
he says there are tools that can help
the cares act still has a lot of
provisions that are in place so you can
really be you know six months behind
even i've seen some as far as back is 18
months behind
however you really don't want to wait
that long you want to call them as soon
as your 30 days pass due levitt says
some homeowners are refinancing their
home to get their payment lowered or
seeking to extend their 30-year loan to
reduce their mortgage you're not going
to lose the home there's so many things
that the cares act put in place at least
on federally backed mortgages that's
going to keep that homeowner in there
because they want to keep people in they
do not want 2008 to repeat itself in
gamboa's case falling behind a few
hundred bucks he says is enough to raise
a red flag and seek any aid available to
keep holding on to his dream home it was
tough to get it and you spend pretty
much to spend all my savings today i'm
just gonna try so hard to just keep
working hard and she's definitely gonna
fight and try really hard to keep my
place
levitt says if you are struggling with
your mortgage reach out for help now the
first step he says can be hard and
sometimes embarrassing but there are
resources available